good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toasted since Thursday after
the ariana grande concert and we are
beat I'm so beat I apologize in advance
I woke up this morning and it didn't go
well and we're talking so slow which is
so unlike us that's how you know we're
not feeling ourselves we always talk
about how we're tired and that's just
like general malaise you know the
struggles of life but today is on
another level for me yeah I mean I
really feel as if I gave all that I
could to the ariana grande concert and I
have so many thoughts there wasn't much
to give is there a story or just like
diving right in no we're there's not a
story about the concert but we always
feel free to talk about ourselves ad
nauseam so I figured we could recap the
concert do you want to go first
yeah well Jax live snitch and I was
sisters in and out which was always fun
you know yes I know it's always a good
time and especially a good time when the
Guardian respects you and lets you go
backstage and like it was really premium
and I just love like I am so vain and
shallow that like I just love any
concert where like I get to be cool you
know a hundred percent
we had great seats like really premium
she had like a big stage like an ode to
Taylor we're like you go into the crowd
so you can see more parts of the
audience and everyone gets to tell like
I guess have an interactive experience I
mean you know a lot more songs than I
thought I didn't realize how a lot of
her music is not super upbeat like even
the songs that I knew like I couldn't
get myself to dance cuz it's more like a
sway vibe yeah
like rocking rights left her outfits
were spectacular like athletes were
probably the best part of this you know
her voice
oh of course and you know I really like
thought she was just like every other
pop star who was gonna sing with the
track like she's saying every song like
really like even though she was singing
on top of tracks sometimes she was
giving it her all vocally and she was
harmonizing on top of herself like I
have I gave her a ten out of ten in
terms of vocal performance like her
vocal talent she's like Michael Phelps
like she just shows up and she wins
because of her talent yes you know it's
not hard for her but she does she sings
a lot on top of her tracks considering
how much she's moving and how little she
is in her heels and everything she's
working hard up there yeah um you know I
honestly have some complaints that I
want to talk about one from the
beginning and I thought it was gonna get
better like where were the lights it was
like truly the darkest concert
can't tell if I'm like getting old or
like I literally couldn't see anything
because she didn't even have a spotlight
following her and the lights that were
on her we're like the color of her
outfit tissues ringing the orange number
so the lights were art and she's wearing
the blue purple number the lights were
blue purple like it was like she didn't
want us to see her and literally she'll
be on stage and be singing and I
literally could have eyed her yeah I
think she'll close that's her vibe is to
be you know like in the shadows darkly
look at her Instagram which is cool like
for her aesthetic but for a stadium
concert and we had good seats and we at
times couldn't find her no-nothing idiom
arena arena the same thing it's a big
arena both of them people in the back
like can't see you and she's already so
little it's hard that's what I was
saying like and the last one I saw or
two years ago I was saying that she kind
of gets lost in like the magnitude of
the stage but it's not even because she
smelled what she is but it's because she
doesn't have a [ __ ] spotlight right
and it's like when you're in an arena or
a stadium that large those two screens
on the side are very instrumental for
60% of the audience who rely on it to
see the whole show for some reason the
size of her screens were like oval and
tiny and so small that like I could see
it kind of fine but like if you had it
just a seat up in a higher row like you
couldn't see anything it was really it
was weird and now I kind of understand
why when I said in my story should I go
hard fifty percent were like yes it was
the best show I've ever seen incredible
changed my life and fifty percent was
like honestly no because if you paid a
lot of money and you were in the pit
like the show was for you she was really
performing for like a good 200 people
but if you were anywhere I was like you
couldn't see or hear anything like I
don't I completely understand why some
people think it was the best night of
their lives because if you spent that
money like tbg was in the pit the pit
standing and he said it was the best
show he ever went to of course cuz he
was like up her vagina but if you were
just in a regular arena stadium bleacher
seat like you could is anything yeah
also her vibe on stage is very much like
her powing around with her friends like
her dancers are her friends they're
saying to each other like dancing with
each other and it's like we're just
watching this group of friends and it
doesn't video net with us yeah she
doesn't like I didn't feel
connected with her where you that's not
so hard to feel at MSG like when we saw
we saw Lauren Alaina there Lu combs like
you feat like I don't know there's just
an amazing pair she's like more invested
in her friends on stage and it's like
watching friends laughs yeah then it is
like a one-woman show because you know I
saw Katy Perry there for the prism tour
which was like the greatest album ever
and there were so much theatrics I had
terrible seats I was like all the way up
there was so much going on and she was
really like a one-woman show with all
her dancers and I didn't feel that
disconnect that I felt with Ariana like
Katy's was so bright like I could see
everything and I was all the way up in
the bleachers you know um and another
thing that was like disappoint I mean
actually not disappointing cuz I can't
tell how I feel about it yet was she's
saying 30 songs which is a lot of songs
she didn't sing full 30 songs she sings
shortened versions of a bunch of songs
which was nice because I got to hear a
lot of songs that I didn't really even
realize that I knew the words to um but
I think I'm an average concerts like 18
to 20 it did feel like she was rushing
through this the show just to get to all
the songs
and she never like spoken between like I
want to hear from are like sometimes
when artists talking between songs it's
like so annoying like please stop but I
couldn't wanted to hear from Ariana
yeah yeah girl they said oh she's had
was good night and how y'all feeling
tonight and she said that at the very
end of the show which didn't make it
clear that it was over so when the show
was over like before the Encore people
didn't know I thought I think they
thought she was coming out again yeah
also I have to say I kind of like when
everyone tries like one-up each other
with their stages and like it's big and
stupid and I didn't mind that her stage
was like pretty sizzle yeah I like that
because she's talented enough like she
doesn't need like fireworks bells and
whistles like things that are going up
just needs to be flying through the air
like that's fine um so the sage wasn't
the problem it was like just I don't
know and it always feels like with her
it's like she's running around her own
stage like when the lights are off like
it feels like she's doing everything
like that it feels like she's plugging
in the outlet I say hooking up her
microphone like she said she's the PA
and she's the talent I wish we could get
an Adele style concert from Ariana like
just a tiny stage you want a dress
looking cute talking between songs being
funny and singing your heart out because
at the end of the day like I went I went
to the concert for Ariana's voice like
her voice is unmatched it's unparallel
maybe one of the best in the industry
right now and like that's what I came
for and they did get that but I just
like could have gotten it I'm like a
more stripped-down level yeah I want to
see your performant like Radio City yeah
I would be Lady gaga does the the Tony
Bennett that's Janet no but like she's
such a big artist and everyone like
loves her and everyone wants to see her
so she can't perform at Radio City
because she'd be doing 20 shows I'm like
that's just no one wants to do that but
there's just something but I think
everyone else had a great time also I am
so old like I'm my ears my ears that
will it's the last concert I will be
going to without earplugs no my ears
were ringing in the cat like and all I
wanted to do was like sit down and drink
my soda yeah like I actually it was the
first time I failed too old because
first of all I didn't realize how men's
were so young like I knew they were
young a few years ago I thought they
were like all growing up together but no
they were still like so many teeny
boppers there that me and when me and
Margo the backstage area didn't have
tequila so we went to the bar in like
one of the main lounges and it was so
empty the guy was like really slow
tonight cuz no one's buying alcohol it's
like kids they're with their parents
yeah but they're having such a great
time like her audience really loves her
and she puts on a great show and like I
love her so much and I just love her as
a person I love her style you know what
I was watching the concert you know what
I was thinking I'm like if Jackie was
ever a pop star like she would do it
like Ariana no I was thinking the same
thing like the fact that she wears the
exact same silhouette since she's 13
because she knows that's what works for
her body like I respected the fact that
she likes her hair up and she wears her
pony like that like I really just relate
to her I'm like a I don't like it when
she was playing that video she played a
childhood video oh my gosh she was so
[ __ ] skinny she looks like she's
acting like you she's nuts
she was nothing what like what kind of
made me sad it's like she has this huge
personality and we know that when you
actually dangerous woman stories Diaries
watches you see like she has this huge
personality anytime she puts out a video
like she's always being silly you see it
in the thank you next video like she
loves all these movies I think she comes
on stage and like she's so quite like I
feel like she can't she doesn't feel
like she could be that my selfie self in
an arena but like we would love to see
that no totally that would like the girl
in that little clip she played is not
Ariana that I know not we know but I
think it's still who she is
you me do but give us more of that I was
inviting me like Joe Jonas tea
and see how like he was so silly growing
up and he was able to like be
appreciated like silly funny guy and
dancing like I need that outlet for re
no I agree I mean totally but oh oh so a
good shell like if I'm gonna leave my
house I'm only leaving it for a premium
experience and it was a good show
I'm like I just want to say it was like
looking like being at her concert is it
so hard for you like not to think about
of course it is I got it the whole time
really is like this spooky but like awed
me on set like you can't not think about
it like with every song like one last
time and we're gonna be alright you
didn't play one last time no but like
there are all these songs from either
that concert 111 and Chester and it's
like even saw a girl in front of us
wearing those like jeans that she was
wearing
yeah one love and I was just like it's
everywhere I know it so there's like a
creepy vibe to the show and then when
you look around and you see how young
her audiences and you're like someone
came for these people yeah like so
intentional innocence the more the most
innocent group of people I think she
might have the most killer pure young
high-grade audience and it's really like
eerie ya know I it was definitely in the
air yeah but and I think she feels that
too and I've seen I've never seen more
security at a show in my life policemen
everywhere
ya know when usually when they liked it
it made me feel safe no totally and
usually when there's like security at a
concert if it's endorsed you like
probably can't jewel yeah and you like
have to hide it but it's like they're
not there to catch you you can jewel
it's not the problem jewel is not the
problem the jewel was the problem
yesterday oh yeah people are okay yeah
Jackie and I are coming out with merch
it for me be next week we'll do another
merch drop of really cool items one of
which is a jewel sticker and before you
go to the website I just want you to
know if you've never drilled in your
life we are not here endorsing
influencing you to do so but if you have
a jewel and you want a cool sticker
feel free to purchase it's you know it's
a free world everyone can do what they
want you don't have to buy the shot
glasses either because shots aren't good
for you
yeah I'm sorry to people who feel
disappointed but we're still selling
them and I like them and that doesn't
mean anybody else should I'm my own
woman and
as are you but I just thought we should
address it no we love like I love the
Snickers we use them we've always been
about like selling things that we
actually want to use and that's what we
wanted and so and so it is in the words
of Alexis Neiers and you are free to do
whatever you want except for in San
Francisco today where they're banning
ething well please so it's not a story
it's not what's not know but I just
thought with an exciting salad I thought
it was time and it wasn't no it's now
time because I also want to share that
right now I'm having my closet
organizers at my house right now the
girls who did my original closet like
things have just like taken a turn since
this last six months and I have like
this one closet in my house and it's
turned into like the graveyard of items
like I'd literally throw something in
and shove the door and I thought it was
time to take Cheaper by the Dozen ya
know it's like friends but you don't
know the reference do you know what even
writer doesn't mom when he's coming home
and they throw all the toys in the
bathroom and that knowing like ya know
that's me and I'm really excited done
and done on Instagram they're like this
cute mother-daughter duo and they're
like are we doing my bags because I'm
just like I'm excited I'm excited for
you I have that coming up for me as well
I can't wait I'm really getting my home
in order now you're inspiring media
mites about [ __ ] time yummy I mean
I've been in my apartment for two months
I should probably open my wedding gifts
which I have and now I'm like now once
you start doing it thing you got excited
then once you do the cleaning then you
get to do the fun things like making a
popcorn cart which is what I'm working
on Hey okay now I feel as though it is
time do you think let me let me check my
watch it did she over the time is it oh
yeah I think it's not you think it's not
okay it is time to deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast but before you do that
allow me to reintroduce myself my name
is Oh No kidding
allow me to let you know that today's
hashtag stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of the morning toast it's brought to you
by Skillshare an online learning
community with thousands of amazing
classes covering dozens of creative and
entrepreneurial skills you can take
classes in everything from photography
and creative writing to design
productivity and more so whether you're
returning to a long time passion project
challenging yourself to get outside your
comfort zone or simply exploring
something new Skillshare has classes for
you lifelong learning is important to me
it actually is if you're doing I agree
ever since I graduated in like learns
nothing in college I'm all about
bettering myself in things that like I
care
pertinent to the situation and learning
something new every day join the
millions of students already learning on
scale show today with a free special
offer with a special offer so heart not
free with a special offer just for our
listeners get two months of skills here
for free okay that's right skill shares
offering the morning to its listeners
two months of unlimited access to
thousands of classes for free to sign up
go to Skillshare dot-com slash morning
toast again
go to Skillshare dot-com / morning toast
to start your two months free now that's
Skillshare comm slash morning toast
totally Jackie you know I was literally
thinking that I used to like thinking
about everything sign-on learn amazing
city amazing yeah okay first story Kylie
Jenner reveals what she said to jordan
woods right after the trypsin Tristan
Thompson's cheating scandal
okay this Sunday on e is the episode
we've been waiting for tryst mageddon
it's gonna be crazy
when did trisomy doesn't happen what
when we were in Utah the second time
which was right after my wedding so they
just filmed Christmas so they stopped
filming and they picked back up no so
they filmed Christmas then we had about
two more episodes where they went to
Mammoth and a few other things happened
and now we're in March they don't it's
not super chronological chronological
but this actually does make a little bit
it's okay yeah yeah it's okay and we got
to cut to the chase of tris mageddon
yeah so they're releasing their little
clips which usually which once in a
while make news for us like you know
you're the least interesting to a guy
yeah but like usually those clips I like
the juiciest it that it gets uh I don't
know for her this episode like I just
wanted to everydayness know because they
lose a clip of Kylie looking like she's
talking to someone okay so they released
the clip where Khloe and Kim are talking
never in a million years did Khloe
Kardashian think that Jordan Woods would
hurt her in this exclusive clip from
Sunday's all-new Keeping Up with the
Kardashians the good American boss sits
down with sisters Kim and Kylie to
discuss what's his betrayal quote
Tristan we've all known what he's
capable of look what he did to me when I
was nine months pregnant there avenged
body star shares but I knew who he was I
never in a million years thought that's
who she was
in fact as shocked Kim reminds the group
quote no one believed the story when it
first chopped me neither
understand Willie since Chloe is her
sister and her best friend Kylie can't
help but be put in the middle of the
drama quote I called her and she didn't
really say anything she was just like
you know crying the whole time
a somber Kylie reveals and I was just
telling her I'm like scared of you now
like you're capable of waking up the
next morning with a smile on your face
not only did the Kylie cosmetics boss
lay into Jordan for acting against the
family but she also informed the 21 year
old the Chi betrayed herself quote I
pretty much told her exactly what we've
all been talking about like you weren't
thinking about true not Chloe not me
Kylie adds nothing in yourself but you
weren't thinking about yourself like
look what you did while Kylie seemingly
suggests she can forgive quite a bit she
makes it clear that the action scans her
family is where she draws the line quote
you could do whatever but when it
affects my family me that's then that's
when it's a problem and then did you
also see Jordan and Entertainment
Tonight in an interview like them
walking weirdly the weirdest thing I
have not wearing a bra it's the weirdest
interview it was the weirdest interview
and then I couldn't I actually couldn't
finish it cuz I was like she was she
didn't know what to say and watching her
try and figure it out was like painful
yeah um and then I was wondering like
had they sync up with her so quick like
this was definitely like pretty she
called them up yeah of course so now I'm
mad ya know me too I really feel very
confused by this entire Jordan what
situation like I can't tell what level
of it is orchestrated because it is so
weird that they have so much footage of
it and like if Jordan is filming this
conversation with Kylie like why would
she agree to that she's not filming the
conversation
Kylie's recounting her conversation with
drove to her sisters okay I don't think
any of this is orchestrated um maybe
what they put on the show is like maybe
stuff happened while they weren't
filming they recreated that's fine by me
as long as I guess the general gist of
what truly happened but this is so crazy
it looks so it was crazy that mean well
tell me talk to me about your Robert
well I was just like so for Clem's this
morning just like with the organizers
and like CEO that I just literally threw
on this piece of trash and they never
realize like how my snatch my shoes in
my dress wear it like I just look so
weird
no why I'm sorry I'm like Cody [ __ ] can
end the show please no it's cool it's it
doesn't it looks good on the show I know
my foots asleep like I'm just really not
feeling well
I know and it's also like Gino tonight
so I need to get my [ __ ] together yeah
they might actually wash my hair we
didn't think this through okay I'm gonna
cruise through the stories then because
also we're gonna talk about this on
Monday after the episode airs right I
hate talking about something that hasn't
happened you know but like I just I also
like to get my thoughts out before
something happens because I'll probably
still probably be different after and
it's always interesting to think to see
what I thought before you know like I
would love someone actually please never
mind okay like I'm just not
next up Paris's my [ __ ] foot is like
dead asleep
who will get some views I will get some
view my gonna show them your feet here
wait put them on display no do not zoom
in on my foot oh please tell me it's
like scription you just have to bang it
okay no no I'll do it
I don't know being from the bottom yeah
is this ASMR oh yeah you guys listen
this is like not helping it's making my
okay
I've just said like I'm having it like a
day where I just don't feel like myself
you know that was my hair feels like a
piece of straw I need you to take a
shower like I actually have gotten like
way ahead of myself like with the
showering you say it's like I shower now
maybe once a week why yeah what do you
mean I shower two times yesterday okay
every time sweetie shower shower
I shower at least every day so they
usually work out but washing my hair I
don't know
oh I wash I'm twice a week wash my hair
a shower at least once a day sometimes
twice no I literally haven't showered
since Monday you're lying
no that's where I caught it your lie
what do you mean I said so you just like
change your underwear and yeah hit the
road yeah you're lying you know I swear
my life
is this a unique week for you like yeah
not just fun like really lazy and my
bathrooms so messy like I just don't
want to go in there okay but I'm at work
today you might know I'm going to animal
wash my hair also yeah that's good does
it yeah your hair looks fine my hair
like when my hair looks good it feels
like [ __ ]
my hair feels good it looks horrible
totally you know 9 feels and looks hard
well today Paris Hilton zendaya support
bella thorne after Whoopi Goldberg's
nude photo reports page 6 they left out
that dove Cameron is also supporting her
as well just one sorry say that again I
was reading the comments everyone's
telling me I'm disgusting like I thought
nobody showered like nobody washes there
everyone says like 80 serene but like we
do it no yeah I know
Paris Hilton ins and I are supporting
Bella Thorne oh good boy loves and taya
is just like my Jackie O note so is dove
Cameron okay
stars are rallying around bella thorne
following her war of words with Whoopi
Goldberg over thorns decision to tweet
out her own nude photos after Goldberg
sent on Monday's episode of the view
that celebrity should know better than
to take photos of themselves
Thorne posted a sobbing video aimed at
the talk-show host that garnered support
Herrmann number of her famous pals quote
at zendaya called me today to make sure
I was okay we talked a lot about this
generation the one before us and how as
women we shouldn't feel bad about our
bodies that's me slut-shaming is one of
the biggest topics of this generation
but yeah we still keep going somehow
it's really sad and then she has like
the can't like the view
she wants to China oh she was in China
the view yeah Thorne also incident say
that explicitly no but she has like that
the ocean the red oh yeah thing Thorne
also Instagram a series of supportive
exchanges from her friends including the
sea hail Madison beer and Lily Rose Depp
and commented when your friends come out
of the Woodworks to support you all you
all you need to be brave that feels good
like when when like you did something
brave but like everyone's supporting you
so it doesn't feel as brave you know no
totally that's like what you experienced
this week I also just look loves India
and Bella Thorne like being back in the
saddle together like are we getting a
rebound of Chicago I'm ready Margot I
feel like if you grew up in Chicago and
there was a show I'd shake it out like
you would have auditioned for it no
involved in death works like I'm not a
good dancer but I definitely would have
watched it religiously you look so like
glowing today yeah what you do
differently
absolutely sweating no but like your
highlight is poppin what you put on your
forehead
nothing you look really shiny like any
good way she's probably moisturized and
then the light is reflecting but usually
it doesn't because she's a lizard and
she doesn't mooster eyes oh yeah did you
know certain lizards and I actually
drink no water yesterday but I did put
on Tarn h2o this morning it's poppin'
okay good it's great thing the PA showed
for class the PA showed the [ __ ] up for
class anyways I'm happy for Bella Thorne
do you think she's gonna get an apology
oh I don't know well I don't want you
view did would be say anything yesterday
I don't know but I feel like it wouldn't
ever been mine s I mean she's like so in
the wrong look she should really just
like let it pass
yeah well that's aunt Bella flowers
totally okay also like while we'll be is
sending a bad message it's also a bad
message like Bella Thorne like not what
not what someone says what you should
affect you that much you know what I
mean
yeah like it's like if you if you live
in this spotlight like not everyone's
gonna always have nice things to say
about you and you can't get like that
torn up over one person's opinion that's
a good point especially because in the
grand scheme of things she is now being
more vocally upset about Whoopi's
comments and she was about about the
blackmail hacks yeah right mrs. woods
like are all these people siding with
her against Whoopie or against the
hacker
I think against Whoopie because the
hacking thing happened a few days before
and now it's so this is what the
response should have been against the
hacker like what we go for it's not the
real enemy here she just had an opinion
that I don't agree with that's true you
know mm-hmm free country no but like
when are we gonna get hacking under
control Tim Cook right it's so crazy how
is it still a problem I don't I don't
get on maybe if you had finished your
computer science degree it's just loud
easily but they can't find an airplane I
read the article wait someone can hack a
cloud but they can't find Amelia Earhart
but no but that was like so long ago
it's 2019 they can't find emergence like
you kid said it's why yanking you can't
permanently delete a photo like from
your cloud I don't know but we can't
find a plane no I know I read the whole
article and boy wasn't interest on do
you want to know the deets honestly no
I'm not one of those people who like
really cares no it's highly interesting
she gave a spark most highly interest
and everyone like there was a thread
about and the toasters people are like
give me the spark like give me the
abridged version they were like no
actually every detail in this is
interesting and it's not like
fortuitously long so basically they talk
about what happened the information they
have from satellite radars because you
just think that when the plane went dark
it went down right yeah
the plane kept flying for six more hours
so when the plane went dark like and
they had all this other radar that they
put together like days later that showed
that in the six hours that when it comes
like towards Antarctica but they work
they conducted the search where the
plane went dark the plane is not [ __ ]
there because it okay so and in the
whole investigation and in the plane
radar signals um everyone [ __ ] up
mostly the Malaysian government which
apparently is a very corrupt didn't know
that also apparently the government is
tied to Malaysia Airlines and I remember
when this happened I actually felt badly
for Malaysia Airlines because it was
like the second plane down any there and
I was like no one's gonna fly like their
sad little airline but this was like a
gross miscarriage of justice in the
investigation like Malaysia's definitely
covering up and when the plane crossed
into Vietnam Ho Chi Minh signaled to the
plane like you know hello welcome to our
airspace or whatever and the captain
didn't say the right thing back he just
said good night mh370 and then went dark
and that person in Vietnam should have
reported that did it
then Indonesian missile defense wound up
seeing the plane later shouldn't have
been where that was yeah and not only
did they exactly know him
it was supposed to be going to Beijing
China not only did they not report the
fact that there is a plane flying an
unidentified object that wasn't on
Raiders because it went dark they didn't
send anything up to look at it because
they could if they send something up
they could have seen who was flying the
plane
they could have seen that probably all
of the passengers were dead had the
kilim the theory is there's a lot of
different theories and there's a lot of
pharisee theories but the theory that
makes the most sense given the evidence
that we have is that the fly lit the
pilot flew the plane up to 40,000 feet
where the plane would have depressurize
people would have taken down their
oxygen masks which only lasts about 15
minutes eventually they would have went
into like a state of unconscious and
died from there but how does the pilot
not die
there's better oxygen tanks in the
cockpit so then when everyone's dead
literally everyone probably died with
oxygen masks on completely silent like
not gasping for air they would have like
slipped into unconscious and died so
there are worse ways to die and so I
mean I guess that's embedded I mean it
all sucks but it's a better way to die
then
when it eliminated the ground when they
hit the water it's like blue into a
million pieces but so it didn't hit the
water six hours later but he killed it
looks like he killed everyone a little
pilot yes a little bit after it went
dark whose idea was it so there's a lot
of theory kill like 600 good people
there's a lot of theories and we'll
never know the whole story because the
Malaysian government that conducted the
investigation on the pilots they said
you know he was in a good mood that day
we looked at CCTV he has he seemed good
he has a wife two homes three kids you
know everything's good he loves to fly
um and then the other the copilot was
like an up-and-comer this was like his
last training flight before he's gonna
become a pilot so when you look at the
two of them
the copilot like has just everything on
the horizon you know Stoli Lilia and
then the other guy when you look deeper
his wife had left him and was living in
a second home she he was like leaving
creepy comments on Instagram models
picture he once used his flight
simulator to do something similar to
mh370 where the plane just runs out of
fuels who had practiced it like perhaps
that's like that might be the smoking
gun anyways there's all this evidence
the most logical theory is that the
captain just it was a suicide mission
but he also needed to kill the other
conscience of people and also I'd love
to comment on Erika Jaynes picture you
see her picture for us it was amazing
anything she's literate bending over a
table of people just like with her ass
out and a common tip oMG she said hey
baby I would respond what I said um I
don't know I was like hey where's mh370
no but like I want have a good response
all right I'm just in the air like it
it's debris it always comes back always
comes back to debris has been washing up
so there's an in this one guy who like
is an American who's really been
invested in this story and he loves to
travel so that he worked with a bunch of
experts once they figured out where you
one of the experts no no no I'm use like
it I'm once they figured out where it
probably
crash-landed which was like off near
closer to Antarctica they started
looking at wave patterns and where it
would have washed
in the years since so he went to the
shores of like Madagascar and wherever
it predicted and he started finding
debris this one this American guy don't
agree who loves ya they found debris so
the plate like didn't bring it to the
government like what ya do when you hand
where he has this whole system in place
but now it's contingent like there's all
this cover-up like and at one point some
of one of the debris handlers who gets
it to the right person like was murdered
but they said maybe he had other shady
dealings and like that's why he was
murdered but it's a whole thing
[ __ ] oh my god well like where are the
bodies I guess like they will decompose
and they probably are yeah also in the
air yeah and it's just like they're at
the bottom of the South China Sea
Oh what you know that's where they
thought they were but there are
somewhere else off of somewhere else
well yeah the bodies but now there's a
documentary show in the deep that's what
I was singing to this would be don't
make a movie about this because what a
terrible ending yeah but a documentary
would be so pertinent to the situation
yeah make how do you lose a [ __ ] plane
I can't delete an email no it's so true
how do you lose a plane no I don't know
it's just the first step flying for six
hours like you don't know where you're
going like what happened to the other
copilot you think he just killed him I
think he either sent him to go check on
something and locked him out or kill him
that's when they said because there's no
way they were in cahoots and the new
co-pilot wouldn't have let this all
happened so he got rid of him yeah for
sure I think that copilot or nothing
with this is for sure but the opposite
99.9 when you there's actually a lot
more I just thought meat had no
information plane gone there's so much
more information than we were originally
led to believe and shout-out to the
Australians who really helm the
investigation and did it as best as they
could because Malaysia really dropped
the ball and the shadow business deals
of the Malaysian definitely it's like
justice for the families of the
passengers cooling system Malaysian
government has a lot more information
than they believe they put out this like
whole report that was literally like
they copy and paste it from the
mechanics of the Boeing plane how the
plane worked but they didn't have any
information it was giving me like three
identical strangers and I was like give
us the Yale study Boeing is like
so shady also like tea bee gees always
telling me I know Boeing's got Boeing
got problems anyways also what was
interesting that the article it gives
you so much information on planes and
how they work in emergency situations
and it was kind of just like a handbook
for the person who wants to do it the
next time and get away with it that's so
sure they feel that way a lot of the
time about like movies like even like
captain Phillips I remember like zero
dark thirty like the way that I know
they don't give away like fake cards but
it's just like knowing that like we
don't negotiate with Harrison if you
think you're getting into a conversation
with a negotiator just know there's a
trap you're not gonna get what you want
yeah that's so true
so it's like I'm glad to have this
information but what if it's it gets to
the hands of the wrong people and how
they know how a cabin [ __ ]
depressurizes look maybe I don't know
the things that's it's so easy that they
just die and people feel like we fly at
30,000 feet but at 40,000 feet it
happens it's like a little too close
yeah you know totally which we flying at
like 15 and like now reading this
article like we just have so much faith
in our pilots who I don't know we've
I've never met them I want to put this
down with each one I think about that
all the time like how much faith we have
in like other people like I every time I
get into a car I think that the cab
drivers will just like t-boned me and
kill me you know yeah didn't we put so
much faith in other people just being
like civilized human beings like
pedestrians I'm just counting on this
guy not running me over he wouldn't die
I would know 1000% we put too much faith
in the hands of other people but what
else you supposed what else are you
supposed to do
yes never leave your house I don't know
maybe I'll just like stop flying okay
we like the flights that the airlines
that we like Delta I'm pretty sure they
are all like prior army pilots like
they're very good vetted you know it's
like if I ever get a jet like anyone can
just lose their mind on a dime right sad
to think it's not about experience it's
about not being [ __ ] crazy
I thought I'm sure the Malaysian pilot
if it was him he was very qualified
years of service but he went nuts yeah
yeah years of service it's all about the
experience yeah so so wild anyways I
thought that sari was full oh yeah or
like if you're waiting for the subway
like you're just counting on someone not
pushing you a hundred percent oh yeah
but it's like when in New York it's like
no they're gonna push you with that it's
all like one to one crime
you know like you would get we would
kill like one person we're like we are
hundreds of people sitting in like a
little soda can hoping someone yeah to
the South China to the bottom of the
South China Sea yeah well I guess now
thank you for giving me a pet yeah give
me someone the idea I mean I didn't give
that idea toasters please don't thank
you we're not that okay you know I'm
gonna use that I was our third story
because that was story yeah it's better
than the one I had chosen okay next up a
little cultural news that is really
pertinent to your situation mine what's
that smell
poll says it may be the young person not
wearing deodorant [ __ ] I don't smell no
no but like this is like you guys
wouldn't even know it I didn't shower if
you didn't if I tell you a new poll
finds that half of young people are not
using deodorant that's vile
this survey by Yuga found thirty nine
percent of Americans between the ages of
eighteen and twenty-four haven't used
deodorant or antiperspirant in the past
thirty days apparently the group isn't
making the decision because of the
perceived health risk but say they don't
use deodorant because they don't think
that they need to
that's so do you think you don't need
deodorant you didn't totally the numbers
were only slightly lower for individuals
between 25 and 34 years old with 31%
making the underarm assertion the
numbers trucks dropped significantly for
adults over the age of 35 with only
about 20% having not used deodorant or
antiperspirant recently okay um as
someone who is now like a natural
deodorant Kourtney Kardashian like
Gwyneth Paltrow the face of you know
goop pretty much I would you say yeah
yeah I would say this is abominable and
just completely unacceptable what are we
teaching our youth totally and it's not
even because you would think like if you
just listen to the culture people aren't
using deodorant because of the chemicals
but that's not even it they just like
think they don't need it yeah like where
are your friends man they don't have any
because they smell right well that's the
thing Marco how okay where are your
counselors counselors always make sure
the campers everybody's ever had an
experience where like someone you knew
or like a close friend like had a
problem with smelling and like you had
to tell them no actually I haven't but I
would I've never
had to tell someone like okay let's say
Dana your best friend like recently just
separating deodorant and really started
to smell oh I could tell her in a
heartbeat because like that's our
friendship I think she can't even move -
okay what about Jake if Jake's smelled
and he was in the studio stinking up the
studio and we need to tell him like how
would you go about doing I couldn't I
couldn't yeah I wouldn't know it's
horrible
yeah you don't smell Jake I was just
making example well anybody said please
tell me if I smelled oh no no I got if I
smelled like I guess I would want to
know excited want to like put an end to
it but I would just like be so ashamed
someone has to help me after this and
Toby if I smell okay do I ever smell you
know
do I ever smell besides my breath my
breath is like rebel is account because
breath isn't hygiene leo
and my breath is worse than all you
[ __ ] but I just talk far away from
you so that you don't tell anybody
myself a statement being like the smelly
growing that when I don't what the
testers should think that marker do I
smell really now you know there's all
the time after you do with you know no
one's but actually I never smelled worse
so then I do after a stand-up show like
I'm always hot from the lights and it's
just like no but like if you smelled
there's every once in a while where
there's like a major hater it's like
it's not Claudia and then she smells I'm
Margo like when we go to Greece we
always bring deodorant oh yeah yeah a
fume in my hair like I don't want to be
smelly yeah
no you don't smell but because 18 to 24
year olds are feeling as if they don't
need to use deodorant and we are a show
for 18 to 35 is that most of the reason
because they just don't think that they
need it we think you're above the
deodorant I guess in every like there's
always so many people who don't think
that they need deodorant but as the
younger generation there's more people
who think that why I don't know that's
so odd and disgusting mmhmm yeah
do you undertake a wonderful thing yes
it might be the best they know it's
[ __ ] genius it is so if you're
watching and you felt like you didn't
need to use Yoda Hrant definitely start
using deodorant if you're writing out
the chemicals Kapaa recom saj toast
go-karting are you also like if you're
and one of the people who doesn't wear
deodorant
I'm just note like your friends are
probably talking about you and that
enough she'd like scary was wearing
deodorant yeah agreed
okay next story a little New York City
news that I found to be quite interest
what's going on in my city v in New York
City anchor women sooo major cable
company over alleged age and gender
discrimination now I want you to guess
what the network is that's in New York
is it Specter like New York one New York
one I find that so shocking because they
really have such a diverse group of
anchors meteorologists hosts well five
newscasters at New York one a New York
City news station that if you're from if
you are from New York you know New York
one they played in every nail salon and
if you have cable spectrum and you turn
on your TV it's always good as to
channel one they're suing parent company
charter communications over age and
gender discrimination in a lawsuit
obtained by The Associated Press the
anchors allege New York one blatantly
marginalize them and cast them aside in
favor of younger women and men
emmy-winning anchor Roma Tory and her
co-plaintiffs a sure no Roma these are
the five women I know her but they're
also like young and pretty so what are
they claiming they are saying that they
would like to return to the positions
they occupied before charter took
control of New York won and are seeking
unspecified unspecified damages in the
lawsuit joining Tory in the lawsuit are
Amanda Farah nachi Vivien Leigh Janine
Ramirez and Kristen Shaughnessy Timothy
if my business sir the middle bottom
where the middle one I think that's
that's Romo Tori of course Roma Tori she
is the heart and soul of New York when
she's no longer on their air they range
in age from forty to sixty one according
to the New York Times we feel we are
being railroaded out of the place Tori
told The Times good for these women men
age on TV with a sense of gravitas yeah
and as women we have an expiration date
Oh Romo
I'm here because she's not on the air
anymore I'm so upset about that also
when we went to the mayoral debate she
might still be on the air but it's clear
that opportunity she feels as though
opportunities are being taken away from
her because Jesus Charter once like the
newer hotter because I was literally
just watching and I saw her so this
would have to be super recent I'm like
literally the heart and soul of that
network heart and soul and New York man
like what is you doing like no one's
watching your network one on purpose or
two because looking for hot
neurologists know like it's it's
misinformation like what are you doing
you're just get the hell out of here
yeah no that's really thirsty of them
and like really disappointing really
disappointing in Roma if you know if you
happen to see this if you're a toaster
and you want to come on the show we are
for you oh my god I need to contact
these women to co-host with me when
you're gone oh yeah at the morning toast
we was just aiming at all ages we don't
see age we don't see gender even know we
don't see anything
so have one block seriously I'm reaching
out to these women because I'm gonna
need co-hosts and you underline cuz I'm
a [ __ ] woman baby oh right
really disappointing justice to Robert
Horry good on these women for unionizing
and taking back their power totally this
is [ __ ] up like you New York one like
do better man truly I mean not everyone
can be as new media as us but is there a
hair ball on the floor yeah it's been
there for a few days really yeah I'm
trying to remember where it came from I
feel as I remember its origin and it's
your origin I don't know like I remember
and I know I've seen that hair ball and
you haven't feel like picked it up or
even told the PA to pick it up um no
because it's not mine it honestly looks
like Margot's it's not mine that's not
mine okay I'm picking it up know what
origin doing gets wrong I don't know but
I remember having like us oh it looks
short as happily it's none of ours you
just dropped it yeah we're picking up
someone else's hair I pick up here guys
is here thank you hey
it's 11:11 make wish I wish I go to my
home right now and it's like the
organizers have just done like such an
amazing job and they like built me a new
bedroom or something I don't know I'm
excited that justice scared the women of
New York 100 great that's much better
use of your wish justice for tomorrow
that I find to within myself to get a
better outfit Oh justice for tomorrow
that we find it within ourselves to put
on a better show and put on a show you
know what we I haven't felt in a really
long time like we did like a bad show I
just didn't feel good about the song oh
I don't think it was bad okay I think it
was funny I think like I was just like
no I think some like it's like when we
then we have no reason to be bad and
it's just like not great that's what is
that like we have every reason to be bad
and we brought everything that we could
talk about tomorrow show let's talk
about it we do have seen you night out
tonight and I just like really want to
like let live and let go and like do
something wild so I'm thinking we should
push the 12:30 okay that could be fun
for a Friday is okay with you is that
okay with you Jake 12:30 tomorrow okay
okay I know you're like super busy yeah
what that actually doesn't work for me
why does I have someone coming to come
to my apartment to do it like a quick
run-through to give me a quote for
something what time time 12:30 can you
move it like honestly I really don't
want to get back on the phone with them
but look you wanna wake up early like no
I really think we should do nothing
worse than waking up at 9:00 a.m. when
you're like you're drinking like okay
12:30 I have my PA call them in okay
great 12:30 I'll see you tomorrow top
there do you think you fill it in the
morning does the Millenial morning show
are you alive Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a big ol thumbs up on YouTube I'm
also available as a podcast for your
commuter youtubes not your thing head
over to Scott if I stitcher Apple
podcast anywhere you can find podcasts
search the morning just to give us a 5
star rating subscribe all the good stuff
share with a friend
the Schmitz our first 10 and podcast
host news network
is just release its fourth episode a lot
of golf things I think I've heard it's a
great episode I have another chance
listen to it yeah but Ben swears it's
like the best one yet so that's the
Schmidt's shb itz also available on
Spotify stitchers podcasts all the
places have a great table see you
tomorrow
you